bars and restaurants and a vibrant
college town like this are always packed
at lunchtime but this place is dead
Lindsay how are you good there you go
let me get you something to drink
Jeff nice cold water okay what would you
recommend very popular it's a little bit
sweeter
I'll try Las Vegas as an appetizer as
well and then it's currently five
individual rolls rolled into one
I don't know how you execute all that
Japanese food on that linear when you're
not trained doesn't make sense
oh this is not good there's not a lot of
people in Starkville that like our sushi
it's a little bit different from what
other places and start will have
[Music]
Sukie ruins our kitchen the way she
wants to it's always takes too long in
between tickets but there was really
nothing I could do about it
this food is taking way too long I've
been waiting over an hour for raw fish
oh my god I can't take this anymore
Damon I know my god
does the sushi usually take this long
yes what is this one Las Vegas all my
girls my cream cheese and asparagus and
it's deep fried and comes with a
jalapenos fight salmon with cream cheese
disgusting
a strange combination anyway it doesn't
work for me that one Amy's just greasy
get this out of the way as quick as
possible okay thank you you're welcome
just my first impressions of the food
here is that it's as bad as the rooms
sukira good that thing so it's pretty
big right so how are you supposed to get
it in your mouth I've never eaten it
before let's try come on me we're in
this together
oh no you order this all on your own oh
that open wine please wait there's no
way this is gonna fit my mouth buddy no
no my grandad feels we puts in your
teeth it so you took one little bite I
do damn disaster total disaster how'd it
taste by the way I'm very good the
Sakura is very chewy
Sookie does tried her best but she has
no idea what she's doing what's wrong
with us
Sakura bland ugly chewy strange
combination chewy
yep and impossible to put you around
let me tell you about my sushi I'm not a
Morimoto or Noble
absolutely I'm doing my best and I
respect rice what is this one
strawberry field man look at that
strawberry on sushi I'm bothering
Japanese chef in America I'd like to
apologize it's very weird which part is
so you wouldn't cover white tuna with
strawberries and then glaze it
sorry failed a rather [ __ ] ear beetle
too sweet strawberries don't belong with
China I am frustrated that Gordon does
not like am i sushi
I tried all I can how you doing honey
bud he doesn't like any he doesn't like
any of it so truthfully what is wrong
with this place lack of business so on
an average weekend how many guests would
you do on a busy weekend maybe twelve
people are they in house guests hotel
usually so virtually nobody from the
outside correct
Jesus anyway we're the owners
can you tell me whether yeah thank you
they've got just 36 bedrooms yet on a
busy night
just twelve guests eat here with food
that bad I'm not surprised
congratulations on the longest plunge
I've ever had in my entire cooking
career that was 97 minutes zero and half
of it was raw as an obvious cook
why are you making sushi it's crazy I'm
trying my best to to at least introduce
Mississippi bless the lipid healthier
there's nothing healthier with my lunch
maybe a health warnings surely you
should be given the locals what they
want to eat that's why they come well
talking to Lindsay the only customers we
get now the ones staying in the hotel
which is practically no one the business
is on his ass and how much debt are you
in over nine hundred thousand nine
hundred thousand dollars
wearing that please don't say you don't
know
[Music]